you had a fascinating interview just a
couple days ago that got a lot of
attention with Kelly and Conway and many
of us who have watched Kelly on Conway
and again I'm trying to almost take
politics out of this just as
performances are saying yeah I don't
have to I mean facts and truth are not
partisan right
Republicans and Democrats all and
independents there are just empirical
facts and we want presidents to tell the
truth well here's the interesting thing
and when I say I agree I agree when I
say I want to take politics out of it
which is I'm trying to avoid I keep
thinking there must be some way that we
can agree on something you know as a
nation and what you have just brought up
I think is the point of agreement which
there should be just this is true and
this is not true once we've you know
gotten through it but if you look at
someone like a Kellyanne Conway and she
is you're interviewing her
it's called pivoting she pivots and so
you act you hold up an orange and say
isn't this an orange and she says that's
not the issue we're talking about apples
and it's this way to never get someone
to say whether something is true or
false as a viewer it's maddening I
thought you did a very good job of
trying to pin her down and it got to a
very bizarre point where she kind of
admitted didn't she it was it was it was
definitely odd it was a it was an
interesting interview and to my boss's
credit he just said keep going blow out
the commercials let's just keep going
with this interview it was a day where
President Trump had said that the murder
rate was the highest it had been in 47
years and that's just not true it's just
false the murder rate was much higher in
the 80s and 90s I mean there's no data
that supports what he said but there had
been other things he said the day before
he had said that the media doesn't cover
terrorism anymore I spent like two weeks
in Paris covering pare ISM I mean two
different times so there were just
empirical lies that the president was
telling and I was challenging her on
them she wasn't really disputing it then
at one point she said
something to the effect of well because
I was just saying you know the president
keeps saying these things and they're
not true in this matters and she says
okay but do those things he says that
aren't true are they more important than
the things he says that are true yeah
that was a that was a moment where I
really did feel like we had gone through
a time warp where she was conceding yes
he says he does lie he tells us he says
things that aren't true but also you're
not paying enough attention to this the
things he does say that are true and you
felt like that was a massive admission
weed that we'd crossed some kind of
weird line that we had never crossed
before well it was just first of all I'd
never heard anybody in the
administration admit that he'd been
saying all these things that aren't true
and Shon Spicer's entire career in the
press room is is there to tell people
that black is white and night as day and
and he's the best president that ever
lived and that's what the daily
briefings are like but yes you had
conceded it but also it's just such a
bizarre formulation what about all the
lines that Nixon didn't tell Yeah right
what about all the presidents that John
Wilkes Booth didn't kill
a lot I didn't tell you there's a great
meme that's been going around of your
WTF face during the Kellyanne Conway
interview looks like you just drank some
sour milk
can I ask you quickly about yeah I don't
make these faces on purpose this is just
my face we've been out to dinner you
know I spend half the time you and I are
having dinner making that face yeah I
know yeah I know why I don't know why
you keep having dinner with me you never
seem to enjoy it that's all I see that's
that's the point where you're picking up
the soup bowl it's a little bit left in
here
you